buongiorno rivali fatah nati sordi
profondi e segnanti la mandante
dell'udito però non pregiudica la
possibilità di parlare perché nostro
apparato fonatorio integro data a sesto
mese di vita ho iniziato a portare lì
pronta per abituarmi a percepire i suoni
mi ritengo fortunata perché l'ho avuto
un team familiare dedita all'educazione
mia e di mio fratello mia madre ha
trascorso numerose oro al giorno
portandomi dalla repubblica sta
diventando lei stessa una logopedista
per continuare il lavoro su di me a casa
la sera dopo piena ritornava di linee
tese stimolando canarini teva ne avrebbe
aiutato a memorizzare i minori pa le
parole il tutto sotto l'attenta
supervisione dei primi nonne utenti
se arrivano compito di correggio in me
la pronuncia mio padre si occupava
spesso dei prati che i familiari
impegnandosi anche a portarne un po
fuori per conoscere il mondo esterno
spiegandomi dettagliatamente situazione
circondava allo scopo di rendere un
autonomo quando a distanza di cinque
anni ma con il mio fratello miei
genitori si prodigarono anche per lui
lo diciamo due giovani sordi che segnano
il parlano fluentemente e correttamente
adesso sto concludendo la laurea
triennale in economia e management e per
spiegarvi la mia idea partirò appunto da
un'analisi dettata in ambito economico
la flotta analysis 1 del grado di
combinare due prospettive che predicano
ritiro dei militari da performance
un'impresa privilegiando da un lato
l'ambiente interno e dall'altro ambiente
esterno da questa modella sostituisco
concetto di impresa con quella della mia
idea e con tette di mercato con quella
della cultura torda infatti cose mie
spalle il modello partendo dai punti di
forza vorrei specificare che per
comunicare relazionarti reperire
informazioni utilizzavano tra canary
viveva abituare a post di deva vocali
perché piano con la vista il primato con
il corpo ma non siamo dei che abbiamo la
lingua dei seminaristi che frutta canary
visivo e ha pari dignità di ogni altra
lingua
le lingue dei segni sono un conto
dittico con propri regole grammaticali
ed un proprio ristico abbiamo anche una
profondità di teva molto ampia vivendo
con la coda dell'occhio per cui
attenzione posta per te state parlando
di me anche il 30 a guardarvi
direttamente un pazzo i punti di
debolezza sono la diretta conseguenza
del non riconoscimento dei rarissimi
tarja ci porta foraggiamento in rimonte
di nanda anno ostacoli ma anche ad una
scarsa autonomia per fortuna lontano
troppi lati negativi in quanto una delle
nostre opportunità è quella di avere una
forte memoria visiva
inoltre guardate un po se io spengono i
miei protesi nel mio silenzio posso
dormire profondamente o posso
concentrarmi durante i propri desideri
tra
credo che possiate prevedere vi era
presenta di pregiudizi che porta a
discriminare è difficile definire la
disabilità uditiva e racchiuderà in
un'unica categoria infatti esistono
sordi segnanti parlanti sword altri
bilingui pre o post in guarin figli di
genitori sordi o nati da farne utente
quel cambio vent'anno comporta diversi
percorsi nella vita quotidiana ma
nessuno finora ha avuto l'idea di una
completa integrazione metodologica per
questo è l'obiettivo di tabris di come
dispositivo ha come maria sandra
ma no scherzavo dare a con apprendimento
bilinguismo lingua italiana si è una
piattaforma di apprendimento chi
racchiudo intere 3 metodologie
necessarie prodotti on evocare bis e
scrittura è un dispositivo con volte da
uno schermo su cui si vito arietta anno
le parole tradotte di montane amia
intendesse dall'interprete o legata ad
una tastiera vibrazionale che
trasformano il suono in vibrazione di
diverse identità dando così un esercizio
loco per i decotti fattiva da piccolo a
in italia i tordi secondo le stime
dell'ente nazionale sordi sono circa
70mila e la piattaforma potrebbe
rispondere sito in the di tutti infatti
dispositivo è destinato dal lato al
bambini a partire da un momento di
rabbia ndoci facilitando così compito
deve farne non più costretta a scendere
una metodologia a scapito dell'altra e
dall'altro al ricupero in età adulta di
coloro che non sono stati supportati
dalla tecnologia aumentando così
probabilmente ra per tentar di sordi
segnanti parlanti fluentemente da 3 su
10 a 7 subiti tutti potrebbero imparare
a parlare vivere struggentemente
divertendosi esercitandosi a casa
braiati nel parco a prendere il sole al
mare
tutte situazioni a cui ho rimontato
l'accessibilità alle informazioni
abbattere barriere comunicative
favorisce l'inclusione risolvendo uno
dei bisogni primari di questa comunità
essere totalmente culturalmente autonomi
sono diverse da chi è l'anti toano
persone di teri a e di serie b con tabs
i sonar e si può basta soltanto un po di
volontà
il volano per tutti compariranno adesso
come talk è finito purtroppo non potrà
sentire va tra prati ma grazie alla
stessa